[Musique]
les décisions finales général on se met
d'accord
son président quand il faut qu'on soit
en général on fonctionne un peu dans un
principe d'unanimité c'est dire qu'on
considère qu'on doit se mettre d'accord
[Musique]
ça permet à l'enfant de s'impliquer est
bon de s'intéresser un petit peu plus et
de comprendre un peu mieux les l'utilité
en fait d'eux des matières qu'il apprend
à l'école
nous sommes au québec mais ce studio est
celui d'une entreprise française ubisoft
une petite pme créée il ya une vingtaine
d'années par cinq frères et qui est
aujourd'hui le numéro trois mondial de
cette industrie des loisirs
électroniques en fait aujourd'hui les
les jeux vidéo vraiment changé
maintenant ce nous créons des mondes
très riche avec beaucoup de personnages
beaucoup de décors beaucoup de façons d
monde en fait
et donc c'est un matériau très
intéressant pour raconter des tas
d'histoires
[Musique]